now it is graduation season which means
many parents of high school seniors
might be thinking about the day your
children actually move out of the house
it's a huge milestone of course but as
kirsten joyce spoke to an expert who
says it can actually take some
adjustment too for soon to be empty
nesters
becoming an empty nester can be an
exciting time no more looking after your
18 year old at home but it can also be
an uncertain event for parents don't be
surprised if you feel the following the
acute feeling of both grief and anxiety
when now we send our kids out of the
home into the real world and that can be
really difficult to cope with licensed
marriage and family therapist emily
pardee says a lot of times empty nesters
need to recognize that even though it's
a normal and known phase of life it can
come with sadness it can feel lonely
even if you have a spouse she suggests
you make extra time to communicate with
your spouse after your child leaves
empty nesters are prone to depression
and other factors that may lead to
dissatisfaction within the marriage keep
in mind the opportunity can also come
with newfound freedoms this can be a
time for self-discovery from some
self-care some new interests or
activities that you haven't done in a
while and it's okay to be able to not
feel guilty for that that this is a time
where you get to learn and relearn who
you are in this next chapter you can
tackle something new and challenging
hobbies for yourself and as a couple add
some new adventures in traveling art
dining and cooking together or
volunteering and she adds the following
suggestion if there are still younger
siblings in the home be a great time to
kind of reignite that relationship in a
new and different way where your
attention isn't spread quite as thin as
maybe it was before and just give them a
chance to also share about how they're
feeling through this experience kirsten
joyce live local now
i tended to get in some trouble when i
was younger and i remember when i went
to college my brother called me he goes
i wish you were still here all the
attention's on me now
you used to get all the attention with
the kind of misbehaving now it's all on
me i was like oh boy you can't get he
goes i can't get away with anything
without you here
they knew you were the culprit all those
years right that's right he was like can
you come back
uh the cbse